hello everybody good morning we're gonna
do a set of part two of a series on the
designing your life program we have here
at Stanford
this one's called prototyping for
personal success and if you did not
attend the first one don't worry about
it it's there there you won't you're not
missing anything by not being there I'll
explain as we go along kind of any
background that you'd need to know from
part one I love this quote from Mark
Twain it's not what we don't know that
hurts us what we know for sure that
you're st. so I know Mark Twain is a guy
that you can get an endless number of
quotes from but I think with respect to
this process we call design in your life
it's based on our design thinking sort
of innovation process this always one
this this quotes that comes to mind
because people that we work with who are
in the process of designing your life
gets stuck and they often get stuck
about things that they're absolutely
sure true that really are and that and
that by I'm part of what we do in the
class we teach here at Stanford and in
the midlife career seminars that we run
off campus is blow up a lot of
assumptions that just aren't true so
let's move on to a couple of things here
so design thinking which is our human
centered problem solving and innovation
technique it relies on kind of this
process diagram where we do empathy
define id8 prototype contest I know
you've probably have seen this before if
you would see many of the other webinars
on design thinking it's a pretty
familiar process and the question is
could you use something like this which
is normally used to design products or
services or innovate in an industry
could you use this on something more
personal like design your life which is
probably the most interesting and and a
difficult design problem one my face
and and you can even restate that
question another way often when we talk
about the class or about this process
people go oh oh I get it this is really
the about the question what do I want to
be when I grow up and it turns out
there's probably three or four major
inflection points in anyone's life where
this question becomes the dominant
question I mean I think we're always
kind of thinking about you know what do
we want to be or how do we want to
change or where we're you know what we
what might we do next which is more
exciting than what we're doing now but
the points in time in a person's life so
seasons of your life where this
questions become predominant and really
you know needs to be answered right
around the end of high school if any of
you out there have you know juniors who
are thinking about college or seniors
who just made a decision about what
college to go to that's a huge
inflection point the person's life and
that decision of where to go for a
higher education or whether to go to
college or not even is one that people
really really wrestle with right and we
worked with a lot of our seniors and
also graduate students are just about to
leave the university and that's you know
wow that's a big inflection point what
am I going to do when I go out of here
what I majored in this but I don't but I
want to work in that how am I going to
make this work and what we call the
decision explosion where all of a sudden
hundreds of options are on the table not
just you know where do I go to school
and what's my major and then you hit a
point somewhere in your 30s when you
know that first career is sort of either
working or not working you they want to
take it to the next level or pivot and
then we're often meeting people sort of
in the fourth big point in their lives
where they're thinking about what people
now call an encore career you know
they've been successful they made some
money they've they've had the job and
the accomplishments that came with it
but now they're thinking about moving to
something else that may be exchanging
the money making for some meaning making
in their lives so these are all the
points at which this question what do I
want to be when I grow up really you
know kind of get some energy I want to
play a little video we're gonna have to
switch switch modes here
this is a video that was actually made
by the guys who do the South Park TV
series but it's from a guy named Alan
Watts Alan Watts was a a scholar a
thinker I think a universe life a
Buddhist priest and was sort of talking
about kind of what's the meaning of life
so we'll play this video it's just real
short and then we'll talk about in a
second
okay so that was Alan Watts life and
music and you know it's it's just a love
for this little piece about what is what
is the point of this journey what is the
point of this search and he makes the
point that it's really music and you are
supposed to be singing or dancing the
whole way through so we've been teaching
this class since 2006 at Stanford in
various incarnations to freshmen to
seniors to master students page these
off-campus and on their results are
really been quite amazing that people
really enjoy having an opportunity to
have a conversation about their lives
and with a kind of a new frame on it and
we're using the Design Thinking
framework and we're gonna we're gonna
make the argument that yeah you can in
fact design a life in fact design is
kind of the most interesting approach to
this sort of thing Socrates said not a
known 2,000 years ago the unexamined
life is not worth living and design is
about the examination of the way things
are and trying to make them better right
when we when I was at Apple we were
trying to make better laptop computers
now they're trying to make better cell
phones and better user experiences on
tablets and things like that but design
is to sort of relentlessly optimistic
thing where we think hey we can make a
future that's better than today and we
do it by really examining what two users
need what two users want and in the
Design Thinking framework we always say
you don't start with a problem we start
with people you start with empathy and
so in design thinking the empathy start
when you're talking about your life is
to really examine who it is that you are
and what it is that you think you want
you know and this isn't an easy thing to
do because if it were easy to know what
you would want and then it was kind of a
linear okay now I'll just go get that
this wouldn't be a hard problem but in
fact it's a very hard problem because
people don't know what they want if you
were part of the first session I
mentioned that we're kind of the anti
passion guys passion works for some
people if you've got a passion you've
always wanted to be a chef you've always
wanted to be a doctor and that that
turns out to play out to be true when
you actually are one that's great
but the research says that only 20% of
the people have an identified
will passion 80% of everybody else has
lots of things they like lots of ways in
which they might express themselves in
the world that they could be excited
about but no one thing rises to that
that one overarching passion and so we
don't like processes that start with 80%
of the people excluded but you can't
examine your life and you can find ways
to design into your future but here's
the thing
we'll make it I want to make a
distinction right now between what we
call navigation and wayfinding
navigation we all understand right we
all have GPS on our phone or in our car
and if somebody says how do I get to San
Francisco to this you know particular
restaurant I just punched the the the
restaurants address into my GPS and it
navigates me to there I go up highway
280 I get our fun you know sixth Street
under that earth at but that's because I
know exactly where I'm going so a
navigation process can give me explicit
directions
the problem with designing your life is
you don't exactly know where you're
going you kind of have a sense of maybe
I like this kind of stuff versus that
kind of stuff again if you joined us for
the first program you did a flow journal
and you did an energy map both and we
had some people send in some great stuff
from the first webinar and we're still
sort of processing some of that
information but that that you know the
flow journal and the energy map kind of
gives you a sense of well what works for
me more often than not how do I start to
understand or examine which things might
be available to me that actually I get
excitement or energy around and so when
you don't know where you're going but
you still need to get there use a
process we call wayfinding that I think
lots of people have used this term
wayfinding is a method of figuring out
where you're going so the way hunters
find game in the wild they know there's
a you know there's a antelope or a deer
out there someplace they know how to
track for signs of the deer they kind of
wander around going from point to point
looking at the next set of signs or
tracks or signals and eventually they
find the deer so we can do the same
thing with finding that thing that
really gets you excited in terms of your
career or other things in your life by
using a process of
wayfinding which is simply to say what
do I know about myself right now what is
available for me to try and when we talk
about prototyping in a second and how do
I get to that next step and the next
step has to be available and it has to
be operational or actionable so the
examines life in this case is all about
practicing wayfinding there's a classic
tension in sort of modern Western world
I think or maybe in all the
industrialized world and that's the
tension between being and doing you know
particularly in Silicon Valley here
everybody's doing something everybody's
got a start-up everybody's you know
trying to actualize themselves through
doing but they're not taking any time to
examine or understand whether the doing
is getting them where they want to go
and particularly the mid-career
workshops we meet a lot of people who
are very successful lawyers
entrepreneurs technologists whatever and
they've made a lot of money and they've
even had a lot of personal success in
their businesses they're the senior
vice-president of something or the CEO
of something but they report that
somehow or other like in the Alan Watts
video when they got to the end and they
opened the bag there was nothing in it
they discovered that somehow in all this
doing they missed the being now the flip
side is you know just just being in the
world as being in the moment and kind of
favoring your experiences doesn't
generate traction or action in the
direction of your goals so if you stay
inside what we call this classic tension
in Western modern society you're kind of
stuck and we don't like being stuck so
we're going to reframe this as what
we're going to call the voice discovery
engine or the the wayfinding engine for
your journey we have the original class
of this we started all this which was
called the designers voice started with
this concept of you know voice who-who
am I was my authentic person when I
speak about something when I talk about
something I have a voice a sort of
authenticity when the things I'm saying
are true for me and so you know when
you're trying to figure out where you're
going you have to sort of try to
untangle all the different things that
are interesting to you
or things that makes a stock or whatever
and this we call the sort of voice
discovery or your past discovery and we
reframe the classic tension between
being and in doing into what we're going
to call the being doing becoming cycle
right so this this engine which
continues to rotate constantly in your
life overcomes the false dichotomy of I
can either be achieving or I can be
experiencing it's really not the way it
works the way it works for people and
the way you discover a passion are you
discover the thing that you want to do
next is to is being doing and becoming
so I I do stuff in the world
I take action I make a prototype by flow
journal I do my other practices and
exercises to try to figure out what I
like right to sort of navigate towards
the next thing in the process of doing
these things I change who I am I change
what's possible for me and then in the
process of that change I be I've become
and and rest in a state of a new
awareness I my enjoyment is increased my
ability to savor has been amplified so
it's sort of like you know I've had
season tickets to the ballet my wife and
I loved the ballet we go every year and
a couple of years ago the ballet started
putting little short videos up prior to
these performance which showed a little
piece of the performance from the
previous year a little voiceover
dialogue from the conductor about what
the music was all about from the
choreographer about what the dance was
all about and I found that by just just
discovering that and then watching that
little eight or nine minute thing before
the ballet all of a sudden my enjoyment
of the ballet is significantly increased
right because I have done something I've
become a more depth connoisseur of the
ballet and now my enjoyment my being at
the ballet is completely different
experience so if you if you just take
this refrain from the false dichotomy of
I'm either doing something or I'm being
something but I can't be both at the
same time and realize it's actually a
sick
goal process that's the first step first
refrain now if you're gonna design stuff
you're gonna make decisions design is
really if you just boil it all down
forget our diagrams and everything else
life's just a series of decisions I want
to make a new copy Cup I have to make a
series of decisions what's going to be
different what will be new well if you
bigger or smaller will be made of paper
or or ceramic so all these decisions add
up to design but how do I know I'm
making a good decision this is the big
thing people wrestle with when they're
when they're stuck tikal these different
things I could do but I don't know how
to make a good decision and we're gonna
argue that in order to make a good
decision you need more than just your
logic because you know the questions
you're asking yourself about life don't
always resolve just by looking at them
logically
so we have this notion that the examined
life requires examination and therefore
you're going to have to get good at this
you're going to have to develop some
practices that this reflective practice
the practice of being able to do what we
call discernment is critical to insight
and decision making and that discernment
empowers a lot of things including how
to get information from the community
around you and how to get information
from your mentors so the keys to this
practice and discernment thing is is
paying attention I'm going to talk about
that a little bit and then ways of
knowing how do we know when we've made a
good decision how do we know when the
decision is right for us paying
attention paying attention is part of
this being and becoming engine and
paying attention has two parts noticing
which is attending to things while
they're happening at the time being
present in the awareness of your
experience right now and reflection
which is attending in retrospect so
being present in the moment attending in
the moment and then reflecting spending
some time each day reflecting on your
experience several several people who
talk about time management and who talk
about being an effective leader and
effective managers say that one of the
most powerful things you can do is after
every meeting after every engagement
after every interview or every ever you
know chunk sort of chunk of your day
stop for a moment just a few moments and
write down the two or three things that
you learned in that moment or the things
that stand out for you and if you just
get this practice of reflection going
every day you become a much better
manager a much better listener a much
better parent you know partner whatever
so we're gonna we're going to talk to to
this issue of noticing and reflecting
because it's critical to having you know
your discernment work in your in your on
your behalf so decision-making
integrating multiple ways of knowing
this there's a attention to the present
and in reflection is what we called the
sermon and to certain you know having
having discernment it's a little
different than just having good judgment
because I think it takes into account
that we know things in ways that are
more complex than simply the logical
irrational ways that we know things so
we're gonna talk about discernment this
is we get the next slide anyway okay so
the cognitive ways we know things and
this is this is our rational mind very
powerful we are for some foremost I
think rational preachers are certainly
we rely on what we can observe directly
and what we have awareness of in that
observation so that's you know making
pros and cons list about a decision
looking at its advantages and
disadvantages
looking at long term and short term
impacts of a decision we want to make
this is this is critical because without
this kind of data it's hard to really
sort through the cloud of all the data
that's in the front of us to make a
decision but there's other ways of
knowing as well which we're going to
just put under the affective category
we have emotional intelligence I cut a
short video out of this piece by a guy
named Dan Goldman Dan Goleman is a
psychologist who developed a concept of
emotional intelligence it's written
quite a bit on it he's got a couple of
great TED Talks
but one of the talks that I didn't put
the video in for he talks about the fact
that there's a part of our brain which
is a fairly primitive part of our brain
called the basal ganglia which uses it's
the place that sort of assesses how
decisions worked and kind of comes up
with what he calls a valence for
decisions I just made this decision and
these were their actions and so I've
that was a positive set of reactions so
I've stored you know that pattern in my
basal ganglia this decision didn't work
out so well people were upset they were
angry so I stored that and it kind of
creates an emotional map for how
decisions have impacted us in the past
and it becomes part of your your
decision-making process in fact he
reports on a guy who had a brain lesion
where this part of the brain was
separated from other parts and no longer
available and this guy couldn't make
decisions at all although his IQ was
still you know 120 130 it's a very smart
person he didn't have the ability to
make decisions because he had no
emotional valence on the decisions so
emotional intelligence which comes from
parts of the brain that don't have
direct access to the part of your brain
that talks to you you know the part
that's listening to me the part that's
that's kind of thinking about what I'm
saying that part which is your
consciousness your awareness is only as
a very small fraction of the of the
processing that's going on about
information and some of the processing
that goes on the lower brain much
amygdala for fight flight or freeze
response to basal ganglia for emotional
valence these kinds of this kind of
information comes to you actually it's
connected to your to your GI tract to
your gut it's connected to other parts
of your body so these feelings you get
in your body are in fact accurate
representation some data that you need
to include in your decision-making
we also have you know sort of spiritual
and and however you want to interpret
that sort of information you get in
other ways of knowing an intuitive call
young the great psychologist said
intuition is a form of perception but
it's perception primarily MIDI mediated
through the unconscious so we get a lot
of data we process a lot of data but a
small only a small fraction of it comes
into our conscious thinking the rest of
it is you sort of as intuitive thinking
and although we don't spend as much time
giving value to that in our culture in
most most cultures prior to sort of
industrialized Western world intuition
was considered of a powerful form of
information for decision-making and then
there's the kinesthetic and physical
kinds of things that we know we know in
our bodies we know through movement we
are embodied intelligences we are over
relying on just the part of that little
three pound bag of neurons in our brain
but the rest of our body has a
tremendous amount of intelligence as
well so tuning in to these multiple ways
of knowing gives us so much more
powerful discernment engine indicators
of knowing of recognition internal
intuition the aha epiphany moment
simultaneity and gut feelings reckon you
know we are massively visual creatures
we are pattern matching creatures we can
match patterns for faces for people for
emotional states instantaneously far
faster than any of and if our most
powerful computers so this notion of
recognizing something is powerful
because the sense of recognition that's
the answer or that's that's the
interesting piece of information that's
actually being that sense of recognition
is being triggered from this massive
database of pattern matching the
internal intuition and conscious knowing
I mentioned Jung's you know statement
that nutrition is a perception via the
unconscious a tremendous amount of
information is being processed below the
level of a part of your brain that talks
to you but it is still valency or
opinions in fact there's a lot of data
now from the behavioral psychologists
that decisions are made at half a second
or more before you actually become aware
of the sort of decisions that you're
aware of we're actually made previously
and you're just being notified of them
they're being made in your unconscious
intentions parts of your brain and when
I use the term unconscious I'm not
speaking of things that are not active
I'm not speaking of a Freudian
unconscious or anything like that it's
just the part of your brain that doesn't
talk to the part of your brain that's
talking to you the parts that you have
awareness of there's aha or inside or
epiphany moment describes in science
described in sports described in almost
every form of humans ever it is a real
moment it's a sudden it's a sudden
recognition and like you know the subtle
or slow recognition formats before
critical to figuring out if something is
right for you these sudden moments of
AHA or insight are really important to
listen to simultaneity is this notion
that like you know have you noticed that
after you buy a car then all of a sudden
all the notice all these are the cars on
the road that it's just like the one you
buy it's not that anything changed its
just your awareness changed when you're
trying to make it you know trying to
come up with a decision about what to do
next and suddenly you know a whole
series of simultaneous connected
simultaneous events occur in the world
and they're all about the thing you're
trying to figure out it's not that
suddenly the world changed it's that
suddenly you're pre-filtering has
changed and you're starting to notice
things that are biased towards maybe a
potential new direction for yourself so
simultaneity is a critical thing to pay
attention to in these the idea of gut
feelings which are emotional valence is
that your body is telling you about
certain ideas so recognition intuition
epiphany moment simultaneity and gut
feelings critical to developing accurate
discernments the forms of doing this how
do you how do you build skills in
discernment how do you build the muscle
of examining your life in a way that
doesn't just create more more confusion
we use lots of different things in the
classes we talked about flow reflection
in the sex section one of this webinar
series we talked about what we call an
energy mapping mapping things that give
you give you or take energy away people
of course for years and years use
meditation have used music exercises
things like yoga as part of their
discernment practices I'm gonna speak
just the two parts of this in addition
to what we did last time
gratefulness exercises and prototyping
so the gratefulness exercises come
directly from the positive psychology
folks Martin Seligman Tekamah hi Dan
Goleman
and others and it turns out to be one of
the simplest things again this is not
even some people do this in terms of a
spiritual practice or a even a yoga
practice
none of those if you do it that way
that's fine but none of that's necessary
it turns out to be just a very very
simple thing as I mentioned in the first
session you know your brain weighs about
two and a half three pounds you know
average human grown human that's two or
three percent of your body weight it's
not very it's not a very significant
organ in terms of size but in terms of
energy it consumes 25% of the energy of
your body it consumes every day so you
run on about 2,000 calories a day and
your brain consumes 500 calories of that
so it's evolved over time to sort of use
as much energy as possible to use more
than that probably the rest of the body
wouldn't have enough energy to run but
even so that's not much that's sort of
like a translate add to a 40 watt light
bulb so the brain is very you know
parsimonious in terms of how it uses its
attention and most of the time you're
not actually attending to things very
much you're just sort of processing and
moving forward because your brain likes
to be lazy
so this gratefulness exercise seems to
work and there's tons and tons of
evidence from a modern psychology now
that this will significantly change
person's mood or setpoint I mean
everybody has a certain set point you
can't turn a Tigger into an ER or any or
into a Tigger or a poo but whatever your
set point is you can maximize your sense
of well-being your sense of thriving
your sense of happiness by simply
spending some time in a couple of
structured ways to redirect your
attention to things that are more
positive this exercise is an exercise in
that regard and it's really quite simple
just set aside ten minutes even five
minutes a day but it's important because
it's a practice that it becomes a
regularly practiced thing in everyday
occurrence leave a journal or a piece of
paper or something next to your bed or
you know whatever you have that you know
a glass of wine or whatever at the end
of the day set aside ten minutes and
think about your day recall today and
look for things or episodes experiences
little moments of things that you are
grateful for jot down two or two to five
of these events exchanges every day and
then focus on them or you live the
experience of that moment just kind of
Reece aber it repeat until all your
moments are complete and that's it and
then every week or so on the weekend
maybe scan that list of things that
you're grateful for if you have to every
day you'll have ten or or fourteen
moments where something happened that
you were grateful for and we're looking
for patterns so we're gonna use both
attention in reflective attention
looking back on something and then we're
gonna use the pattern matching skill
that we are neatly born with to see if
we can find pattern in this set of
episodes that we're grateful for now
this is this can be super simple things
like the lady at Starbucks smiled when
she my coffee and said have a nice day
and I just noticed that that was sweet
or you know I was
I forgot my headphone
on the bus and I was just about to get
off the bus and somebody next to me said
oh did you drop these and it's like oh
that's great because I was you know who
stuff fun all the time and it's nice
when someone picks something up for me
so it doesn't have to be you know
somebody you know rescued my dog or you
know saved my life this is just small
interventions in the day where you're
going to try to look for a positive bias
the data says that if you do this he
makes it a regular part of your practice
within six to eight weeks if this
becomes a habit and psychology tells us
it takes about eight weeks to form and
you have it people surveyed pre and post
this simple practice have a
significantly higher sense of well-being
a significantly higher sense of energy
is significantly higher sense of you
know their their happiness and sort of
agency in the world when that starts to
happen and and you notice patterns of
these behaviors you will start to
unconsciously provoke these behaviors in
yourself and others and that will lead
to new opportunities for prototypes new
things that you could try and then start
you on the path of way finding yourself
into the next you know version of you
when you grow up which brings us to the
the final thing that in design thinking
paradigm we spent a lot of time talking
about prototyping you can prototype new
products new experiences you know when
the whole notion of Design Thinking is
if we're going to invent something new
we're kind of inventing the future but
you can't get any data about the future
nobody knew what the iPhone was until
they started sort of tinkering around
and building prototypes and trying
different things and if you read the
first biography of Steve Jobs you know
that they turn he turned the iPhone down
three times because it wasn't good
enough so it was a constant and
relentless process of prototyping and
trying things and saying is this but
gonna work and then when we when we say
is this what's gonna work we show it to
lots of people and then they change
their mind about what they want and then
they tell us new things and then we just
keep doing that until we finally invent
something that people recognize they go
oh that's what I wanted well that's what
we're gonna try to do with prototyping
our way forward in lives
in our lives we say and to Deesa go we
say building is thinking it's not that
we think of something and then go make a
model of it and say how about this we
actually use the process of modeling or
prototyping to think our way forward so
this is a form of practice in life's
design prototyping and prototypes of
prototypes are experiences that you
design to ask an interesting question so
this isn't just necessarily completely
solved the problem although sometimes
prototypes do end up solving a problem
or a question that you've got but mostly
we create prototypes to ask an
interesting question what would it be
like you know I've got a lot of students
who come to Stanford and they want to
become there they will they enter the
pre-medical major we have a couple of
majors here that you can do for pre-med
because they want to be doctors and I go
why do you want to be a doctor they go I
don't know I've always wanted to be a
doctor I think that's that's great do
you have any idea what a doctor actually
does every day they go know like oh whoa
that's an easy that's an easy question
to ask but it's not to do it every day
and since we have a big Medical School
here and the doctors are always looking
for students to work in their labs it's
pretty easy to go find out pretty easy
to go get an opportunity to shadow a
doctor or spend an hour with the doctor
interviewing you know a dozen doctors
and finding it with actually do everyday
interesting in that situation most of my
students come back and go wow you know
mostly it's really boring I mean the
part about surgery was cool but all that
rest them it seems really boring so a
prototype is a thing you're designed to
ask him interesting questions they're
really the only way we know to get data
about your possible future and you want
them to be as low resolution in this
brief and it's inexpensive both your
time and your money as possible because
you want to run lots and lots and lots
of prototypes it's this design iterate
design iterate building your way forward
is the methodology and so you're
constantly looking for ways to say well
what's them what's available but what is
possible for me to do can I get ahold of
a doctor can I get ahold of a person who
does this thing I'm interested in doing
and spend some time with them and
Michael Schrage who wrote a book mit
press called serious play
I've done a whole PhD study on how
prototyping impacts the quality of
design so it's a great book and he says
you know the value of prototypes rely
less than the models themselves the
things you create but in the
interactions they invite you often go
out asking one question with your
prototype and come back with a whole
bunch of different answers to other
questions that turned out to be more
important than the one you thought you
were asking so forms of practice for
this examples of prototyping in a life
design scenario are an information
interview you know 80% of the jobs are
never listed and so people who say I
mean I tried send their resume into
everything on the internet I didn't get
any didn't even get any answers back I
go great well you've only you've only
hit 20% of the possible opportunities
out there and the rest you're not going
to find on the internet by the way this
is a tip sending resumes into internet
posting posted jobs has about a 2 to 5
percent hit rate so you can send in a
hundred and maybe get two answers back
and they're done even lead to interviews
and and also by the way about half of
the jobs that are listed on the internet
have already been filled in that most
companies have a practice of saying hey
if you want to hire somebody you have to
post the job so if I know I want to hire
corinne to be my you know my facilitator
for my executive programs i'll post a
job with a description of someone who
it's just like corinne wait to one week
I have to wait by temple by my company's
rules and it's just hire the person I
was gonna hire anyway so most of the
stuff you see listed isn't actually real
but I digress back to the prototypes you
know but you can have an information
interview which is a great way to find
out if the thing that you're interested
in doing even exists and whether it's
really the thing you think it is you can
spend the day shadowing someone this is
fantastic you know students do it
professionals do it it's amazing the
kind of information you get about people
and the conversations you'll have during
that day that might take you down you
pass what we call a pop up experience we
often run some of our most popular
classes now at Stanford blast a day or
two or a three a weekend so you can
create pop of experiences to see if you
wanted to do the thing you want to do
one of the things you do with
entrepreneurs
is have them you know just pop up a
version of the product or service that
they want to offer in its crudest form
and see if they like selling it for the
for a weekend we're actually about to
have head off to makers faire here and
the value this weekend is the big makers
faire event and I've got all about eight
of my students team at makers faire
trying to see if if when if people
really like the products they've come up
with and - if they really like spending
48 hours in selling mode if not they
probably not entrepreneurs you can
create internships everybody loves to
have an intern and they would love it
even more if you don't the Pam and one
week unpaid experience doing what you
want to do which is surprisingly
available you'd be amazed at the number
of yeses you get when you offer to be
the intern for a week even I don't care
if you're you know 16 22 35 or 50 and
then internships although I we also kind
of internship should become farther down
the line a three-month engagement in
some kind of an organizational
opportunity is a pretty expensive
prototype in terms of time and money and
what I've found in interviewing all of
my students who I'll go off and do
internships in the summers is that they
knew within the first week or so whether
this job was the kind of job that that
it would really get excited about in the
future and so the rest of the other nine
or ten weeks for the internship were
pretty much so step-and-repeat although
they I have taught them that and while
you're the intern your opportunity to
have informational interviews is
enormous I mean you can even take the
CEO for a cup of coffee and find out how
he or she got to be CEO so these are all
ways in which you can prototype your way
into a future that that you know has a
little more data around it so pick a
problem you're dealing with in your
career here's my challenge to you pick a
problem you're dealing with brainstorm
at least three as always three never
more than never less than three three to
five is great three completely different
ways you might approach or solve this
problem ask yourself what's the fastest
low-resolution way you have to ask the
question embedded in my solution so we
had an executive who was you know pretty
successful executive and I
firm but had always wanted to you know
had it had a sort of a dream of opening
her restaurant I always wanted to open a
restaurant and sold all her stock quit
her job found a location spent six
months designing this amazing restaurant
and restaurant experience opened the
restaurant and discovered it was very
very successful and six months in was
miserable and we asked her why she said
well I realized after but I liked was
designing the restaurant actually
running a restaurant it's just a lot of
hard work and then people come and
complain about that food and the staff
doesn't show up on time it's it's it's
not any fun at all you know and we were
thinking gosh that's a pretty expensive
prototype to run you quit job you sold i
stunk you invested everything in the
rest buckley she was able to sell the
restaurant at a profit but um the she
could prototype you know take a week off
and you know and be the house manager
you know in a friend's restaurant or
something to discover whether or not
that would have worked but but the
question you know the question she
failed to ask was what would it actually
be like to operate this on a day to day
basis not to design this and she could
have unlocked that one of my simpler
prototype so find out the lowest way the
most fastest most resolution way you
have to ask the question and then
develop a prototype that is actually
available and cheap availability is this
idea of wayfinding what is actually
available to me I can't probably go
become the CEO of a major tech company
and try it out that's not available
it is available over took you know
network on LinkedIn find a couple of
friends who knows some people who are
you know senior executives and
organizations and take them out for a
cup of coffee spend a day shadowing them
are offering to be their intern for a
week so what I'd like to do is same
challenge we had last time if folks are
interested in trying this and they want
to report back on their progress either
with the gratefulness exercise or with
interesting you know prototype as
they've run report back to me and let me
know how it would how it worked
we'll try to you know correlate that
stuff Megan on
non personal information and figure out
how to share it with people who
participate so that's yet I think we've
got maybe ten minutes for some questions
just the takeaways would be you know we
do believe you can sign your life and
frankly you have to because if you know
your life is going to happen whether you
design it or not here the only question
is whether it's going to be a good
design or something ad hoc really it's
just a series of decisions but to make
good decisions you have to develop your
discernment and discernment is more than
just logical decision making it includes
the intuitive the emotional the
spiritual and the physical information
that you have at your disposal
gratefulness exercises amplifies
positive effect and creates a sense of
well-being in a sense of engagement in
the world which helps you to discern
what's working for you you can prototype
any kind of future experience start with
low res look for an interesting question
and practice in life makes perfect and
frankly what else what else you're gonna
do I mean you're either life's going to
happen or you're going to design it and
you're either going to get better and
better at it bike being in a constant
learning mode which is the sort of
design thinking empathy you know
prototype mode or or or not kind of up
to you okay you know we've got a bunch
of questions here and we probably can't
get to all of them but I've got three
that I think are kind of interesting one
comes says any advice on how you get
start with low resolution prototypes and
solutions being an engineer I have
trouble not being able to start unless I
have a high fidelity solution with all
the permutations thoughts or at least
well well listed so I mean this is this
is a great question and it gets us to
the domain the idea of what's what's the
domain of the problem you know
engineering I'm trained as an engineer
and engineering thinking powerful way to
solve problems you you you know you list
all of the possible permutations of a
solution and you optimize the solution
now for an engineering problem to work
you have to have enough data the sister
system has to essentially be a closed
system there has to be knowable what is
what is knowable and if you have
unknowns you have to have enough
information so that you can solve for
the end
but if you have an engineering problem
this is a pretty good approach right -
so to optimize around all the data and
come up with one good or one optimum
solution fantastic now the the let's flu
let's go to the domain of the problems
we've been talking about them design
your life designing a new product for
people whose needs are just emerging
like that we don't even really know you
know before we had smartphones you
didn't know you needed one it wasn't
clear that that was the right direction
you know it's a kind of an unbounded
space so design problems that I'm
thinking works best when the problem is
unbounded or you can't get data about
the future and we're over investing in
the kind of prototype solution that was
described in this problem it's gonna
turn out to be a waste of time and money
because although you've optimized around
everything you know as soon as you
propose the solution the user you are in
this case I just gonna change your mind
and you're gonna say that's not what I
want anymore now that I've seen what
you've shown me this optimized solution
I don't want it I know an engineer will
said but that's not fair you told me
this you gave me all the parameters I
gave you exactly what you wanted and now
you've changed your mind but they know
that's just what it is with human beings
we change our mind when the situation is
exposed and that's why you won't you're
going to fail and you want to fail fast
and you want to fail early in the
process
failing meaning asking a question
building a low-resolution prototype
discovering that's not what what works
at all for you and then moving to the
next prototype because if you over
invest in the solution ie you quit your
job and open a restaurant only to
discover you hate running restaurants
you know you you've spent too much time
and too much energy and money in this
case on prototyping something for which
you could have gotten that data much
more quickly
so remember engineering solutions for
engineering problems to design solutions
for design problems there was another
question
how do you prototype decisions that are
one-shot that can't be made again for
instance the critical ones like choosing
one's career this is an interesting
question because embedded in it is the
notion that I am going to choose a
career and then I'm going to act on that
career so I deal with this question all
the time my students come in and say
what should i major and then they pick a
major and then go well my major in
engineering I had to be an engineer
rest of my life and I'm Adrian
psychology of course I'm going to be a
counselor if I major in in computer
science I'm going to be a programmer
it's like and and the data if you if you
want to if you want to think that way
you can you can think it's a one-shot
decision but the data is quite clear for
instance with respect to college majors
only 20% of the students 10 years out of
school be doing anything professionally
that had anything to do with the
qualifications they received in their
major ie
they majored in mechanical engineering
and now they're using mechanical
engineering in their career so it just
doesn't work that way the fact is and
particularly for this generation and
whatever generation you are it's been
true for a long time now that everyone
will have at least two completely
different careers in their lives which
utilize on different skill sets and
different different strengths and
probably this generation which will live
to be a hundred and work for sixty or
seventy years will have at least three
different careers so then I'm sure that
it's a one-shot deal is is not true you
can hold that opinion if you want but
the data tells us that's not true
and in fact wood wood isn't it better if
it's not true would you really like your
18 year old self who went to college and
picked a major to decide what your 50
year old self has to do now I mean are
you sure the council from that 18 year
old is the council you want to listen to
don't you think something has changed in
your life and in your experiences and
and haven't you grown in certain core
strengths and observational abilities
for which you would now be so much
better suited for a different potential
career again I'm not arguing that you
know if you have one career and you love
it I have had a career in design and
I've loved it but it's but it's been as
an engineer as a designer as a project
and company leader as an entrepreneur
now
an educator and my next career will be
purely as an artist where I'm gonna
practice my love of creation and design
but not on the markets terms on my terms
so I think the notion that a career
decision is a one-shot deal I'm hoping
to blow up because the data tells us
that is that is not true and then there
was one more question that was really
kind of fun oh okay can this be applied
to testing testing relationships and the
two relationships they suggest are maybe
with a new business partner or even with
a spouse
okay so I'm not a I'm gonna you know
kind of somewhat opt out of the spouse
question I absolutely think you can
prototype you know relationships I think
that's probably one of the most
important things to do and that's where
your discernment and your emotional
intelligence and your ability to sit
quietly with yourself and understand you
know is this love or is this in passion
infatuation is this truly passion or is
this just you know something that will
fade next weekend
those are really important questions but
I don't know that I'm qualified to speak
to that I do know that a critical we do
this all the time we have a class called
lunch pad where you have to actually you
know it's an entrepreneurship class
taught by my colleague Perry clay bond
and in the 10-week quarter because we
have short quarters here at Stanford you
have to conceive design launch and and
and create your company so and the
critical part of that is forming the
partnerships that will create companies
the data on entrepreneurship is really
clear single entrepreneurs are rarely as
successful as pairs or trios anything
pesto trio is pretty fragile and doesn't
work so we are constantly forming and
reforming pairs of entrepreneurship
teams for this class and we go through a
rigorous process of testing how are you
with conflict how are you with what is
your communication style do the Styles
match all of those things can be
simulated prototypes built and
experienced and that's where your guts
going to tell you
probably within a couple of days if you
really are serious about you know a
partnership business partnership of
simulating all the experiences that you
know not the easy ones like hey
everybody loves our company and they
gave us five million dollars but that we
have no money no one likes our business
plan and we're fighting over direction
if you you can easily simulate those
kinds of situations and discover what
people's behavior is and how their
behavior works for you there is no right
or wrong kind of partnership other than
one that you know where the
communication works your conflicts can
be resolved and people can get on the
same page that can happen with lots and
lots of different personality types lots
of different learning styles lots of
different you know kind of
organizational styles but that's
something that you absolutely can
prototype and discover up front whether
or not the partnership will work for you
there's a couple of things a couple
things we we can pull from other sort of
relationship psychology but there's a
thing in psychology about sort of the 1
to 5 ratio for every conflict you have
with a partner you need to have 5 you
know positive engagements and/or for the
partnership to be operational both in
you know business operation and in
personal relationships so you know if
you can't find a sort of 1 to 5 ratio of
conflict to positive engagements with
someone you're considering partnering
with our suggestion would be that's
probably not going to be a viable
long-term partnership lots more to say
about relationships and stuff but I
won't get into that now I think we're
pretty much out of time so I'll turn it
back to Corinne so thank you again
everyone for joining us today there will
be more information to come with their
recording sent out within a week have a
great day